und er backt ein bisschen boden backt
kriegt noch ein sehr gutes programm
verband kommt weil das ja richtig warm
stimmung hier herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen mein kopf wie heute spielen
wir in time auf timo ja und ich habe
eine ganz besondere change für euch
nämlich die fifty fifty challenge die 15
ihr so immer wenn ich mir ein gutes oder
nützlich ist nützliches altem kaufe so
wie zb dieses stein schwert hier muss
ich mir danach irgendwas kaufen was
kompletter ramsch ist zum beispiel jetzt
ein holzschwert dass wer kommt wer
absolut unnütz für mich aber ich darf
mir jetzt nachdem ich dieses gute alte
mich das ständige kopf erstmal kein
weiteres gutes items kaufen sondern muss
als allererstes mir irgendeinen sport
holen jetzt der challenge so ok das
heißt zum beispiel wenn ich mir jetzt
irgendwas kaufe was wir nichts bringt
wie zum beispiel rotten flesh oder
irgendein gelingt diese spyder
das ist perfekt dieses beide eis bringe
überhaupt nichts
deswegen habe ich mir die mal und ich
habe auch mal dann wieder als gutes
altem die golden carrot ist eine
knackige challenge heute probiert das
gerne mal aus fifty-fifty challenge sie
deswegen weil man eben abwechselnd gutes
und schlechtes kauft und auch nur jedes
zweite mal gut sein darf dann
logischerweise und das ist gar nicht so
leicht
das ist nicht okay was bringt mir jetzt
gerade gar nichts okay die sticks sind
unnötig für mich die bringen momentan
überhaupt nichts ich kann mir kann die
gewichtskraft damit deswegen darf man
das kaufen
so jetzt müssen wir ein gutes auto
kaufen und ein großes problem dabei ist
auch über leute dass man einfach extrem
wenig zeit hat die zeit rennt einem
richtig davon weil man ja die ganze
branche items kaufen muss hier wenn
jetzt diese wunde ex kaufe da ich mir
danach mit kaufen gibt es sieht mich
nicht kommen
was los alter wie es am lodern wurde am
lecken alter uhr gedauert da was war das
okay meiste gold fällt und ich musste
mir nicht mal kaufen
gut ich habe mir als letztes außerdem
ramsch gekauft nämlich wurden ex das
heißt ich dachte jetzt wieder was gutes
kaufen muss aber ich muss aufpassen dass
ich mal derzeit im blick habe ok waging
porsche bringt nichts sich sogar banken
gerieten aber damit kann ich momentan
nichts anfangen okay es gibt es in der
mitte zeit verteilung an die bedürftigen
aber ich will mich noch ein bisschen
besser ausstatten
ein kompass kommen jedoch den kompass
mit der kompass etwas nützliches feature
direkt morbusch dazu okay die feder ist
unnütz alles klar das heißt ich darf mir
als nächstes wieder was nützliches
kaufen und erst in die mitte gehen und
ein bisschen falten ok konzentrieren
davon ist nämlich schon einer der mitte
sehe ich doch ich hoffe auch dass meine
grafik nicht schon wieder abgab meine
oma otti feierten die weiten fahrten
drauf doch dafür drauf ich habe nämlich
immerhin wieder opengl es okay okay okay
alter hat er den anderen grad rasiert
hat er den halter des efi drückt und
jetzt das gap oder so gutes equipment
group und der nächste gegner ist eine
ganze weile ganz ganze weile entfernt wo
reiter ist das geiles equipment man [ __ ]
my life das ist richtig nice ich glaube
ich muss gar nichts mehr einkaufen noch
ein eisen schwert alter junge ich habe
acht rüstungs punkte
ich bräuchte noch einen besseren helm
theoretisch praktisch auch aber egal wir
laufen es erstmal weiter
vielleicht und ich muss auch aufpassen
ich hab so wenig zeit jetzt eher was ist
zu wenig aber relativ wenig ich will
jetzt wirklich aufpassen ist mir die
zeit nicht strich durch die rechnung
machen diese aufnahme wenn es schon
nicht driver ist alter drei achsen
rasierten leben
ich kann auch nicht die viel zu hoch
laden ist ja dass sie auch scheiße das
ist mein problem so der kommentar der
opengl opengl schaut mich nicht
mach was immer ein open-air macht oder
sind zwei leute sind zwei leute sind
zwei leute alles klar
ihr folgt ihrem team der energie es
nicht oder nee da klingt hat ihn getötet
prokino auf diesen tag hin drauf da
klingt es geht
daten fakten die schwerter bot er macht
gute turnaround alter der macht mir
richtig guten turnaround
das war nicht so staubt dadurch kleine
kleine kleiner kleiner lex aber es war
nicht so schlau gemacht von mir so wie
dreamer das ding jetzt richten kann
alter schwede okay ich feiere bogener
das kann ich vielleicht zu meinem
vorteil einsetzen wenn ich jetzt hier
die ecke gop das noch nicht so dumm
gelaufen jetzt hier vielleicht nice
aber ich habe ja noch mal nein er ist
ausgewichen nicht sein ernst aber du
bist jetzt gleich fällig mann du bist
jetzt echt da gleich fällig man lieber
mein lieber freund du bist gleich fertig
ist das spannend es richtig krasse crypt
der ist auch richtig gute club aber er
kann auch er kann auf jeden fall so
wahrscheinlich nicht essen würde ich mal
sagen deswegen weil wir einfach mal
nimmt dran wäre jetzt vier minuten noch
zeit also wir können ganz weiterlaufen
das ist gut meist bekommen ist ein alter
who nicht so schlau wie lang zu laufen
von dir mein freund hat dieses equipment
mann ist das krass oder ist das krass
komme ich mit dem 2 4 weg ich muss mir
nicht alles kaufen weil ich einfach so
gutes equipment ab das macht die ganze
challenge für mich deutlich leichter ich
weiß auch gar nicht ob ich mal etwas
gutes oder schlechtes gekauft habe ich
würde vorsichtshalber wieder heimisch
kaufen nämlich die challenge nicht nicht
vorher das will ich auch nicht und
hoffentlich will dass ihr seht dann hat
mein grafiktreiber mitgespielt und ist
nicht abgeneigt wäre ich fange gerade so
man könnte sagen ich bin um mein leben
gibt gibt ihm richtig damit ich überlebe
kommt schon kommt schon kommission jetzt
ist die spannende frage sie haben in der
mitte was kann ich gegen die dahinter
mache okay das war richtig schlecht
die sind richtig schlechte kritiken was
war das wieder was war das wieder von
ping mit alter dann werde ich wieder
angepackt wenn ich sage hacker aber was
war das bitte für ein hit man holy cow
da kann ich ja nichts machen gott alter
schwede
aber es reicht um reiter muss zuerst das
nämlich angreifen kann und die anderen
bürger wohl noch nach gepackt sehr gut
und weil die möhren die beste sättigung
im spiel haben kann ich jetzt mal eine
ganze weile spenden
aber ich habe auch nur noch drei minuten
zeit muss man auch so sehen so sei es
okay es down und er hat eine motion die
ich mir gerne mal ein stecke alter
schwede
jetzt schaue ich jetzt dauernd hat mich
gut erwischt denn brauche ich aber nicht
aber ich muss dringend in die mitte
gehen ich muss dringend in die mitte
gehen denn ich hab nur noch drei minuten
zeit
hier machen wir sonst machen hier gleich
die zeit und strich durch die rechnung
alles mögliche machen strich durch die
rechnung ich habe mich richtig richtig
gutes equipment neue händlers ball in
der mitte
okay es geht in die mitte nur noch drei
leute mit mir inklusive drei leute leben
noch zwei gegner und ich werde vom
wetter mit euch das ein name is born is
da ist ja noch
so wird fast sagen gegen den sich dann
meine passion ein sieht er mich nicht
kommen alter nämlich nicht kommen sid
kevin ok hab mich kommen sie in scheiße
aufpassen dass wir außerhalb der porsche
range bleiben und immer den kompass im
auge behalten 29 29 blöcke wäre es grüßt
von viatu hat er mich erkannt wird die
flüchtlinge vom dlr dumm wenn du das
jetzt kauft euch die fluglinien jetzt
sofort ihr scheiß pcs mit dir da draußen
was machen wir mit dir in kontakt kommt
schon leute ich sage einfach mal
provisorisch sollte der opengl 3 aber
noch mal abhaken im laufe dieser
aufnahme dann entschuldigt ist auch die
runde bisher war so richtig weiß ich
glaube ich werde auf jeden fall leben
auch wenn jetzt abgehakt aber das sollte
nicht der fall sein msi hero und kam
schon das ok hat den ersten passiert und
er backt bisschen gewagt kriegt noch ein
sehr gut vertreten parteien comcom dass
er richtig war die stimmung hier
richtige hektik so der kann ein bisschen
abkürzung ich laufe ein bisschen bessere
rot als er
ich darf nicht zu weit vom sport weg
laufen denn ich habe nur begrenzt zeit
den fehler mache ich nicht noch mal habe
ich letzten schon in der aufnahme
gemacht habt jetzt noch nicht gesehen
aber ich mache den fehler ist hier nicht
noch mal okay weiß was mach dein ding
ich gehe nie meter diesmal lasse ich
mich nicht von euch verarschen diesmal
gehe ich nicht drauf wenn ich zeit habe
ich in der mitte da kann mir ähnlich
gefährlich werden manche machten
rüstungs puncto erschwert könnt ihr mir
höchstens noch motions reindrücken
dann wäre ein problem für mich aber muss
einfach aufpassen um mich darauf
vorbereiten dass sie mir eine porsche
reinwirft und bis dahin vielleicht in
der mitte bisschen shoppen okay aber
dass immer der nächste gegner
es ist nur noch der was mit dem anderen
passiert ist er weg
ok ich weiß auf jeden fall nicht wie
viel zeit er hat das ist jetzt eine
blackbox für mich weiß nicht wie viel
zeit der typ hat was ist los mit dir
ja mann der weiß blaue widersinnig so
viel zeit der demut
ja ja ich verstehe deine taktik schon
ich hab das alles für mich blickt wisst
ihr hinterher lauf und dann mir die zeit
ausgeht dass die exportlastigkeit dass
alles gut ich bleibe hier jetzt weiß ich
was er will er will glaube ich stören
dass ich zeit hier kriege bwb bwb
das kämpfen kämpfen kämpfen kämpfen er
ist dann gegangen alter ich weiß nicht
ob mein schwert getötet
was ist die zeit wo die cic hat
funktioniert der drei weiß nicht
abgehakt ich bin dankbar
danke schon heute das gerne daumen nach
oben und das gefällt wie soll nächsten
video wieder rein macht gut und